some people for instance love the
metaphors that come out of say
literature and the arts and think that
you want to leave those whole and and
untouched by an analysis as to why we
may like those metaphors or why those
metaphors seem to help our thinking or
any of a number of questions and there's
a sense that if someone goes in and
assesses that situation and gives a
biologic dimension to why we do like
those things that somehow it's all
diminished by that and that's that's
just not true in my early part of my
career and continues I study patients
who had their two brains disconnected
what we were responsible for was working
out the functions of each hemisphere you
could work with them independent of the
other influencing it so you kind of got
the study it alone and over many many
years the basic finding is of course
that one brain didn't know what the
other one was doing and such people that
the information doesn't transfer between
the brains we found out that in the left
brain there's a special system that
seems to always want to explain actions
and moods that we have after they
occurred so we would put a question to
the right non-speaking hemisphere and it
in effect would direct the left hand to
do something and so the patient would do
that and then we would simply say to the
patient well why did you do that the
patient would make up a story that would
explain why their hand had done one
thing and why the other hand had done
another thing and wove a tale that made
coherent the as it were the behaviors
that are coming from all these separate
brain areas the behavior comes out and
then there's this little narrator up
there that turns it into a story that
makes this feel coherent and unified
turns out it's a thing in the left
hemisphere it does this and we called it
the interpreter and it's a very powerful
force in the human condition and it's
always trying to figure out and seek
explanations for
our behavior that's that's what it does
I think the the human as the
story-telling animal is some people put
it is because this system is continually
trying to keep the story coherent and
even though these actions may be coming
from processors going on outside of
initially of conscious awareness an
action is produced and then do you have
want to explain that action is to be
part of your coherence in your story
your narrative why does the human always
seem to like fiction what what is that
it could it be as some people have
suggested could it be that that prepares
us for unexpected things that happen in
our life because we've already thought
about them in our fantasy world and are
are right about them in a fictitious
setting and saw how those characters
acted and so then when we're confronted
with it we're ready we've we've sort of
lived through that movie as it were so
why do we like that stuff well maybe
that's a reason why we like it and to
think of all of those things seems to me
just to make it all richer a richer
experience
you